[Musique]
tout cela et plus à venir dans la
clandestinité d'aujourd'hui, mais d'abord
les géants pharmaceutiques se sont précipités aujourd'hui pour être
les premiers
à breveter un vaccin contre le coronavirus
subventionné par les contribuables des
superpuissances pendant la soi-disant
guerre froide, les États-Unis payaient une grosse
drogue  entreprises
pour une raison très différente de
fabriquer du lsd
pour le projet de contrôle mental de la cia connu
sous le nom de mkultra
un nouveau livre empoisonneur en chef par l'ancien
correspondant étranger du new york times
stephen kinzer fait la lumière sur mk ultra
et l'homme derrière sydney gottlieb
me rejoint maintenant depuis le cap  morue dans le
massachusetts
steven bienvenue dans la clandestinité
avant même d'arriver à ce livre incroyable
votre réaction à cet argent du pentagone de 40 milliards de dollars
semblant entrer dans le prochain
paquet de secours contre les coronavirus apparemment votre pays a besoin de
f-35b est un sous-marin d'attaque de classe virginie
quoi que ça  est
et une sorte d'
armement à énergie dirigée pour cibler la Chine,
il ne semble y avoir aucun aspect de la
politique publique, y compris
les soins de santé aux États-Unis qui
ne
deviennent pas en quelque sorte la propriété de notre
industrie de l'armement,
il est vrai que dans le gros projet de loi pour la
soi-disant
réponse au virus corona, nous
trouvons soudainement tous ces nouveaux programmes militaires
les horreurs dont mon livre parle
qui se sont déroulées  dans les années 1950 étaient
justifiés
par ce concept que tout le monde semblait
partager aux États-Unis selon lequel
les peuples épris de liberté
partout dans le monde faisaient face à
une menace imminente qui était si dangereuse,
si horrible dans sa portée que
nous devons temporairement mettre de côté certaines de
nos priorités et  certains de nos
principes éthiques et moraux,
mais nous y reviendrons certainement
très bientôt dès que la crise sera terminée,
la crise ne semble jamais se terminer
et bien que le communisme soit terminé en tant que
boogeyman,
il y a toujours du terrorisme, il y a la Chine,
il y a l'Iran à la recherche de  les ennemis
aux états-unis sont implacables
dites-moi juste qui sydney gottlieb est
donné que les directeurs de la cia
peut-être votre secrétaire d'état actuel
pom  peo et encore moins euh
regina haspel dirige maintenant la cia n'a peut-
être même pas entendu parler de sydney gottlieb
avant la sortie de ce livre sydney
godley dirigeait l'un des projets secrets les plus importants
de l'histoire des
états-unis
son identité était totalement inconnue du
monde extérieur  même à l'intérieur de la cia, il n'y
avait que de
vagues idées sur ce qu'il faisait, en
fait,
ce type avait un permis de tuer délivré par
le
gouvernement américain.
le titre du livre dit
mais qu'il était vraiment l'américain inconnu le plus puissant
du 20ème siècle
maintenant vous faites beaucoup d'allégations
contre lui je dois dire
bien que nous ne puissions pas diffamer les morts comme nous
savons qu'il l'a dit dans une affaire judiciaire il pouvait  Je
ne me souviens pas que les choses ne me souviennent d'aucune
des choses dont vous parlez dans
le
livre en 83 est mort en
1999 ici, la statue de Churchill
est attaquée par des manifestants Black Lives
Matter
ramenez-nous juste à l'époque où Churchill
voulait des armes biologiques, alors pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale en 1944, Churchill a
été convaincu par des rapports de renseignement
qui se sont avérés plus tard
faux que le gouvernement nazi
prévoyait d'armer certains de ses
missiles v2 qui pleuvaient  sur
londres
avec des armes de guerre biologique
donc churchill n'ayant pas les
installations lui-même
pour créer des contre-armes a demandé à franklin
roosevelt
de préparer pour lui des dizaines de milliers de
bombes à l'anthrax qu'il tiendrait
prêt
à contre-attaquer contre l'allemagne
alors roosevelt a accepté de le faire et il a
ordonné  l'
armée américaine pour lancer un projet secret pour créer
ces bombes à l'anthrax et elles étaient en
cours de construction dans une usine en indiana
lorsque la guerre a pris fin, c'était donc la
demande urgente de churchill à roosevelt sur la base de
ce qui s'est avéré être de fausses informations
qui ont mis les états-unis et  à travers
les états-unis le monde occidental sur
la voie
des armes biologiques et je
vais g  et au
recrutement par la cia de médecins nazis nazis
en une seconde, mais encore une fois, le contexte ici dont
nous parlons est
euh la corée euh la grande-bretagne les états-unis ont
peut-être tué
un cinquième de la population coréenne pendant la guerre de corée
vous dites dans le livre que la cia  pensait
que nous, soldats,
leur soutien au communisme, leur
soutien apparent ne pouvait s'expliquer que
par des médicaments psychotropes,
alors quand je travaillais sur ce
projet
mk ultra le projet de contrôle mental de la cia
qui est au centre de mon livre l'
une des questions qui ne cessaient d'émerger
dans mon esprit, c'est
ce qui a amené ces gens au début de la cia
à croire que le contrôle de l'esprit était réel
pourquoi ont-ils passé 10 ans à détruire
tant de vies
dans l'effort d'essayer de trouver un moyen de
détruire un esprit humain afin qu'un nouvel esprit puisse
être
placé  là à sa place
euh je pense qu'il y a deux raisons l'une d'
elles a à voir avec
le conditionnement culturel pense à tous les
livres et les films
les histoires de sherlock holmes les histoires d'
edgar allan poe
a  à propos du contrôle de l'esprit et de l'hypnose, je pense
qu'inconsciemment, beaucoup de ces personnes de
cette génération,
la génération qui dirigeait la première cia,
ont été
affectées par ceux-ci et ont commencé à perdre la
frontière entre la
fiction et la réalité, mais il y a ensuite
eu quelques
épisodes spécifiques euh qui sont tombés en
quelque sorte  en tant que graines sur ce
sol déjà fertilisé, l'
une est celle que vous avez mentionnée dans laquelle euh des
prisonniers de guerre américains revenant de
corée après la fin de la guerre se
sont avérés dans de nombreux cas avoir signé des
déclarations critiquant des aspects de la vie
aux états-unis que
certains avaient avoué  commettre des
crimes de guerre en corée,
quelques-uns avaient dit qu'ils avaient largué
des
bombes biologiques sur la corée du nord quelque chose que les
états-unis ont toujours consisté
ne s'est jamais produit comment auraient-ils pu dire
ces choses
euh la seule explication que la cia
pouvait trouver était
que d'une manière ou d'une autre leur esprit avait  ont été
saisis par les forces communistes hostiles et
donc
ces gens ne parlaient pas pour
eux-mêmes,
quelqu'un parlait  les brutaliser et
donc
puisque nous avons maintenant des preuves qui se sont
avérées fausses par la suite
que les communistes ont une capacité de contrôle de l'esprit
ou la développent, il est
absolument
urgent que nous, en tant que projet défensif, nous
impliquions dans la recherche du
contrôle de l'esprit et c'était sydney god laisse un
aperçu  qu'avant de pouvoir trouver un moyen
d'insérer un nouvel esprit dans le cerveau de quelqu'un,
vous devez d'abord trouver un moyen de détruire
l'esprit qui s'y trouve et il a passé
10 ans à
expérimenter sur la plupart des victimes malheureuses
essayant de trouver des moyens de détruire un
esprit humain et  un esprit humain dans un corps humain
vous avez mentionné le contexte culturel je
veux dire ce sont
des gens de la classe moyenne blanche de la ligue de lierre il y a une
dimension de classe
mais même eux comment diable ont-ils
accepté euh d'
embaucher des nazis euh des
personnes impliquées qui étaient impliquées dans
euh l'expérimentation dans les camps de la mort je
veux dire en particulier
sydney gottlieb lui-même ce que euh ses
grands-parents étaient des survivants de l'holocauste c'est
vraiment une partie fascinante o  f l'
histoire
donc à la toute fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale euh
le chef de nos services secrets américains
l'oss a
écrit une note au président roosevelt
disant que comme le
régime nazi s'effondrait il serait
important pour le
gouvernement américain d'essayer  pour embaucher des espions nazis
et les amener à travailler pour le
gouvernement américain,
roosevelt a rejeté cette idée, il a dit que
nous n'allions embaucher aucune de ces
personnes,
mais après quelques mois, roosevelt était
mort, truman était au pouvoir
et ce processus s'est poursuivi après le
très
immédiatement après la seconde guerre mondiale
euh les responsables du renseignement américain
arrêtaient de nombreuses personnes en allemagne
et ils avaient des dossiers sur eux si vous aviez une
formation scientifique
ils mettraient un trombone sur votre dossier
donc donc l'
opération trombone est devenue le nom
du projet
par lequel  les nazis ont été amenés aux
états-unis
et c'était un processus qui impliquait
quelque chose appelé blanchiment
parce que les dossiers de ces personnes
devaient être blanchis toutes les références  à l'
appartenance à la ss ou à la gestapo
devait être désinfecté
il y aurait peu d'entrées faites sur
ce qu'était un bon père de famille cette personne était
donc le premier groupe qui est venu était cinq
puis le deuxième groupe était le
spécialiste des fusées qui était verner von braun
puis est venu  la troisième pièce nos
gens de
la guerre biologique les gens qui voulaient savoir comment
contrôler les esprits
humains se sont dit qui est là
-bas qui a des informations que nous n'avons pas
qui a expérimenté des gens à mort
pour savoir exactement quelles portions de
quels types de poisons  avoir quels types d'
effets
sur l'esprit humain et le corps humain eh bien
ce sont les médecins des camps de concentration nazis
et les experts en guerre biologique qui
travaillent pour le troisième reich
la partie sur le plomb de dieu est particulièrement
intrigante
car vous dites que pieux était juif ses parents ont
émigré d'europe centrale  au
début du 20ème siècle
s'ils n'avaient pas émigré et le jeune
sydney aurait bien pu être
victime de l'un de ces horribles
so-  appelé expériences médicales dans un
camp de concentration nazi,
mais dans le cas où cela ne se produirait pas, il
a grandi aux États-Unis et il
ne semblait pas avoir de problème à
travailler côte à côte avec les
médecins nazis qui ont mené ces mêmes
expériences
peut-être le  euh les sénateurs qui ont travaillé sur ce
euh
comité sur euh la torture à propos de guantanamo à
propos de dabou grey
peut-être qu'ils devraient certainement
lire ce livre parce que ironiquement je
suppose prévisible qu'ils puis
ces médecins nazis ce personnel se livrent à des
tortures épouvantables en injectant du lsd dans les afro-
américains
électricité drogues vous  parler d'
empoisonnements de masse à san francisco, vous avez
tout à fait raison,
le projet a complètement
déraillé en grande partie à cause de la volonté de Dieu,
donc la pièce de san francisco n'était qu'un
exemple,
vous avez raison, cela impliquait des
expériences horribles sur des sujets humains et
un nombre inconnu de personnes  mort mais pieux
avait aussi toutes sortes d'autres intérêts l'
un d'eux était lsd en 1953
sydney godley persu  a ajouté la cia
pour acheter la totalité de l'offre mondiale de lsd
et il a utilisé cela à deux fins, l'une
était ces
expériences horriblement coercitives visant à essayer de
détruire un esprit humain,
mais l'autre était pour des expériences moins coercitives
, y compris ce
programme bizarre qu'il a mis en place à san  francisco,
il voulait voir s'il y avait un
lien entre les drogues comme le lsd et d'
autres et le
sexe, alors il a demandé à un gars de san francisco de
travailler pour lui et d'embaucher
un cercle de prostituées, leur travail consistait à
aller
chercher des mecs les ramener à  un
appartement spécialement équipé,
ils y seraient nourris de lsd et leurs
réactions seraient surveillées par un
agent de la graisse qui n'avait aucune
formation scientifique et était juste assis sur
des toilettes portables en train de boire des martinis dans
un pichet,
cela s'appelait l'opération minuit
climax
et donc ce national  le bordel de sécurité
faisait partie de l'effort américain pour se
défendre contre le communisme dans les années
1950 c'est comme ça que le fou mk ultra
est allé me parler des incon
énients involontaires euh  séquences les conséquences culturelles
en termes de contre-culture des années 60 et
bien l'ironie de cela a à voir avec
les
euh expériences que Dieu voulait
mener sur des gens ordinaires
donc en plus de ces euh utilisations du lsd
soit
sur des prisonniers soit sur des personnes qui ignoraient
pieux  voulait également voir comment une
personne ordinaire réagirait au lsd
euh dans un cadre clinique sachant exactement
ce qui se passait
alors presque du jour au lendemain, un tout nouveau marché
pour la recherche sur le lsd
a grandi, les gens sont venus et se sont portés volontaires, l'
un d'eux était ken
keezy l'auteur de quoi  est
devenu ce grand classique de la contre-culture
qui a survolé le nid de coucou en fait,
il l'a pris dans un hôpital et l'a tellement
aimé qu'il a trouvé un emploi
à l'hôpital de l'hôpital de l'
administration des anciens combattants à menlo park en
californie,
c'est ce qui lui a donné le matériel pour
ce livre fantastique allen ginsburg le
poète radical était un autre des tout
premiers volontaires
à utiliser le lsd aucun d'eux n'a compris
que le lsd qu'ils utilisaient c
moi de sydney gottlieb et de la cia
clairement tu vas aussi citer
john lennon qui a dit merci la cia
sinon euh
gottley je comprends euh le
programme d'assassinat a
été prolifique parle moi de euh
peut être qu'ils sont mieux connus le
castro fidel castro
tentatives d'assassinat de raul castro che guevara par
gottlieb et aussi patrice lumumba donc le
titre de mon livre empoisonneur en chef
fait référence à l'épisode dont vous
parlez c'est la campagne
des états-unis à la fin des années 50 et au
début des années 60 pour assassiner des
étrangers  les dirigeants sydney godley
étaient à la tête de la branche chimique de
la cia,
il était donc logique que lorsque la
cia avait besoin de poison
pour n'importe quel but, y compris tuer un
dirigeant étranger, il serait la personne vers laquelle
ils se tourneraient, en
effet, c'était sydney godley qui a
composé le poison qui  était censé
avoir été utilisé pour
empoisonner le chef chinois joe et lai
ce complot a été avorté
plus tard fidel castro est devenu
la cible et c'est pieux qui a créé  d
tous ces appareils élaborés dont il a lu,
il a non seulement fabriqué les
pilules l c'est une phrase que j'ai apprise en
écrivant ce livre en langage d'espionnage
l phillip l signifie mortel donc une
pilule l est une pilule qui vous tuera il a
fait ceux pour castro
mais  il a également fabriqué des choses comme un
stylo plume empoisonné avec une pointe ultra fine
pour que vous ne sentiez même pas s'il entrait
dans votre jambe,
il a fabriqué une combinaison empoisonnée de sorte que si
castro la mettait dessus, elle rongerait
sa peau,
donc évidemment rien de  ces complots ont été
couronnés de succès
lorsque la cia a décidé, sur ordre du
président eisenhower, d'assassiner
patrice lumumba, le premier ministre
du congo,
non seulement gottlieb a fabriqué le poison
qu'il a transporté de washington
au congo, ce qui, je pense, fait de lui la
seule personne
dans le  l'histoire des États-Unis
pour avoir transporté du poison fabriqué par le gouvernement
dans un autre pays destiné à être
utilisé
pour assassiner le chef de ce
pays, nous ne savons pas sans doute que
ces assassinats se poursuivent dans votre livre
y  ous citez richard helms dit que
la principale force motrice était le procureur
général robert
kennedy vous dites qu'il y a une ironie qu'en
fait euh un agent de la cia à paris
recevait un stylo empoisonné
le même jour que euh comme malcolm x a dit que
les poulets sont rentrés se percher et
le frère de jfk robert a été tué tout
ce que vous pensez de l'
assassinat de kennedy
toutes les théories sont liées d'une manière ou d'une autre à
cuba si c'était oswald seul c'était
parce qu'il était en colère nous savons contre les
attaques que les états-unis faisaient sur cuba si
c'était castro c'était  une vengeance si c'était
les cubains anti-castro
c'était parce qu'ils n'aimaient pas que Kennedy
abandonne les gâteaux en papier c'était parce
que c'était les
salviens c'était à cause de cuba si c'était la cia
et
les éléments voyous de l'
appareil de sécurité nationale  c'était parce qu'ils étaient en colère
contre kennedy à propos de
cuba l'obsession de cuba n'a jamais
quitté le gouvernement américain en fait
parfois quand je vois l'intensité avec
laquelle nous voulons punir et sanctionner
cuba encore à ce moment  Je pense que
nous sommes toujours en colère contre fidel castro et
bien nous ne savons pas combien de centaines de
millions de vies peuvent être affectées
par toutes ces décisions de politique étrangère,
enfin
ce qui est arrivé au camp dietrich qui
figure tant dans ce livre
associé  avec plum island euh parce que
bien sûr il y a un complot en fait
l'été dernier le représentant américain des
républicains christopher smith a dit que la
maladie de lyme aurait pu être créée par
camp dietrich c'est une maladie 300 000
américains
sont diagnostiqués chaque année hors de ce qui est camp
dietrich
maintenant bien euh fort  dietrich comme on l'appelle maintenant
était le centre de développement des
armes biologiques américaines
et des agents biologiques en général
il est maintenant utilisé par exemple pour un magasin comme
une installation de stockage d'
antidotes à d'éventuelles maladies mondiales
c'est là que sydney godley a
maintenu une
petite cellule secrète euh dans  quels
scientifiques de la cia ont concocté leurs poisons et
effectué leurs autres travaux
maintenant, on ne sait pas quel type de recherche
est encore  Je continue derrière certaines des
portes closes
du professeur de port, mais il est certain de le dire
bien que nous ne sachions pas à quel point le
gouvernement américain se lance dans la recherche
sur la guerre biologique, dont certaines sont
limitées
par un accord international quel que soit le
gouvernement américain.  faire dans ce domaine, cela se
passe à huis clos
sur cette base du maryland la même base
qui était le centre de mk ultra l'
endroit où les poisons ont été
fabriqués et l'endroit où il y a
la recherche la plus
avancée en cours peut-être
partout dans le monde
sur les moyens de  militariser les bactéries ou se
défendre contre ce type de
militarisation, donc le
camp dietrich joue un rôle vital et très
obscur dans cette cartographie mondiale de la
guerre biologique et l'enquête
sur les outils biologiques qui peuvent être utilisés à
des fins politiques dans le monde
stephen kinza merci
bien loin de la cia  maintenant à une autre
agence gouvernementale américaine sans doute infâme de la
glace ou de l'immigration
et de l'application des douanes comme coronavirus
et bl  ack les vies comptent, les protestations continuent de
faire rage,
il menace d'expulser peut-être tous
les étudiants étrangers des États-Unis,
mais un avocat spécialisé dans l'immigration et
ancien étudiant international
riposte fiona macanty
me rejoint maintenant via skype depuis chicago
merci de m'avoir rejoint pour
euh  des millions d'
étudiants internationaux ont reçu les
visas d'étudiants américains l'année dernière,
qu'est-ce qui est menacé
contre eux,
merci de m'avoir fait agir euh
je suis un peu mystifié
par cela et donc essentiellement plus tôt
cette semaine euh la
glace a changé de cap en ce qui concerne
les allocations pour les étudiants étrangers qui
ont été en quelque sorte rendues
pandémiques et essentiellement ils ont dit que
si les étudiants étrangers allaient
étudier en ligne ou suivre des cours en ligne
uniquement pour le semestre d'automne
, ils ne pourraient pas le
faire tout en maintenant
leur étudiant  statut de visa ici aux
états-unis maintenant je connais harvard et mit
ont déjà dit qu'ils allaient poursuivre
l'administrateur de l'atout  tion, je veux dire que cela
pourrait vraiment signifier
l'expulsion massive de, disons, tous les
étudiants britanniques des États-Unis,
eh bien, je veux dire que c'était certainement ce que la glace
avait mis dans leur directive
qu'ils ont émise, ils ont essentiellement laissé
des étudiants étrangers qui allaient
assister en ligne uniquement  des cours avec quelques
options et je ne pense pas qu'aucune des
options
ne soit excellente et la première est de laisser les États-
Unis deuxième essayer de se précipiter pour transférer des
écoles dans quelques semaines en supposant
qu'ils peuvent trouver un cours dans une école qui
n'est pas en ligne  seulement
et forcer les écoles à continuer à passer
d'une sorte de changement en ligne uniquement à en
personne euh ou
faire face à l'expulsion et donc ce sont les
options qui leur restaient
et je suis en fait ravi de voir que
harvard
mit a déjà poursuivi et  l'université du nord-ouest
de chicago et
vient de se joindre récemment à l'appui de la
position de harvard et du mit également
maintenant je sais que vous avez tweeté une échappatoire
une échappatoire possible je ne sais pas si
vous faites de l'
humour à propos de  J'y reviendrai dans une
seconde
tout d'abord pensez-vous que c'est
sérieusement une reconnaissance par
ceux au pouvoir aux États-Unis que les
étudiants sont des consommateurs euh mais ils ne
contribuent en
rien à la société des États-Unis
quand ils sont là-bas  Je veux dire que c'est certainement
une gifle pour les
étudiants étrangers qui sont venus
et je ne le comprends tout simplement pas d'un
point de vue économique et
toutes les données économiques montrent à quel
point les étudiants étrangers contribuent simplement
en vivant ici
vous savez euh 41 milliards de dollars et ils ont
investi dans l'économie américaine au cours de l'
année universitaire 2018-2019
et rien qu'en étant ici, leur seule présence a
créé plus de 450
000 emplois ici aux États-Unis et donc au
milieu d'une pandémie alors que l'économie
souffre  à bien des égards, je ne sais pas
pourquoi
il est logique d'essayer d'expulser une énorme
population d'
immigrants qui contribuent clairement
tant
maintenant, passons à cette échappatoire qui
pourrait sauver les étudiants qui regardent ce
programme dans le monde entier.
e quelque chose comme un cours à un
crédit qui pourrait les sauver de l'
expulsion ou
leur capacité à retourner aux États-
Unis pour reprendre leurs études
et je sais que les collèges et les
universités étudient cela et
il y avait une disposition
pour euh un modèle de type hybride où ce n'est
pas en ligne  seulement
et cela pourrait potentiellement permettre aux
étudiants étrangers et de rester,
mais je pense que si l'administration trompait l'
administration et la glace
essayaient de forcer les écoles à ouvrir
et je pense que leur plan n'a pas vraiment
fonctionné car au lieu de le faire,
ils ont en fait poursuivi l'administration
et donc je conseillerais aux étudiants étrangers
de
communiquer clairement avec votre université
et de rester assis et de regarder l'espace pour voir
ce qui se passe avec ce procès,
mais techniquement, si une université est allée
en ligne à cause du coronavirus
et qu'elle n'a qu'un tout petit cours
peut-être un demi  pendant une heure que euh est
face à face que cela voudrait dire qu'ils
ne seraient pas expulsés par la glace eh bien
ils essaient de comprendre ceux
détails,
donc il y avait des dispositions pour vous savez que
la directive ne parlait qu'en ligne,
donc je pense qu'ils essaient de
comprendre exactement ce que cela signifie et
et quels sont les paramètres de
cela euh et donc
ça fait toujours l'objet d'une
enquête  par les collèges et les
universités, mais je sais que j'avais lu
cela et je pense que vous savez que presque tous les
professeurs de certaines de ces grandes
universités se sont portés volontaires pour
venir donner un cours en personne parce
qu'ils savent à quel point les
étudiants étrangers sont importants.  économiquement, mais aussi
ce sont des vies de gens et
j'étais moi-même un étudiant étranger,
donc défendre les étudiants actuels et étrangers
est quelque chose qui me
passionne vraiment et vous pouvez simplement dire
que ce sont des professeurs, vous savez qu'ils se
soucient beaucoup  à propos de ces étudiants qui
viennent du monde entier et ce n'est
tout simplement pas juste et la position que la glace
a prise
étant donné que le virus corona est, vous le savez,
absolument pas sous contrôle dans  ce
pays
et mis à part les près d'un demi-million d'
emplois perdus peut-être
41 milliards dans l'économie américaine, des
centaines de milliers de propriétaires fonciers peuvent
être affectés en termes de
logement étudiant aux États-Unis ouais et en
fait c'était l'une des choses que
euh j'avais  fait un entretien et presque
immédiatement plusieurs propriétaires
m'ont contacté directement pour me
dire qu'ils louaient donc ils
louaient leurs logements à des étudiants étrangers
et que s'ils étaient expulsés, vous savez
qu'ils me demandent ce qui va arriver
à leur
leur appartement  donc j'ai en fait
recommandé qu'ils envisagent d'écrire une
lettre au rédacteur en chef de
leur journal local juste de leur
point de vue parce que
vous savez que ce n'est pas seulement assez grave
que ce soit directement sur les
étudiants étrangers, mais il y a un énorme
effet d'entraînement à
partir de cela et et  une partie de cela inclut
l'impact que cela aurait sur les
propriétaires qui louent à des étudiants étrangers
au moment de cette interview, Joe Biden
n'a pas été  a poursuivi n'importe quoi
du delaware sur ce qu'il ferait s'il
gagnait la maison blanche en novembre
obama et biden a expulsé beaucoup plus que l'
atout plus que tout autre président
de l'histoire ou tous les présidents
réunis obama était connu comme le déporteur
en chef
peut-être plus que  deux millions et demi, je
veux dire tout signe euh qui en
fait biden pourrait être pire que l'atout
sur ces problèmes d'étudiants étrangers
non je ne pense pas qu'il y en ait
il n'y a absolument aucun moyen que
euh biden va vous savez mettre en œuvre
ces types de politiques
euh  et je pense que j'ai en fait
regardé euh c'est en ligne mais j'ai
lu le plan du vice-président biden
pour l'immigration il s'est engagé
à réformer l'immigration pour le mettre à
l'ordre du jour dans les 100 premiers jours son
plan est des adresses très complètes
à la fois les aspects humanitaires de l'
immigration comme les demandeurs d'asile
et vous savez en plus d'envisager
une réforme de l'immigration d'affaires,
donc vous savez juste le fait
que t  le système est obsolète et ne correspond pas
nécessairement aux besoins,
donc je ne doute pas dans mon esprit qu'il n'y a
aucun moyen que nous voyions quelque chose comme ça
euh
de biden fiona mackenzie merci